لقد قمت للتو بزيارة مستشفى غزة الأوروبي
والأشياء التي رأيتها
هناك تفوق أي شيء
يمكن لأي شخص أن يكون في وضع يسمح له بوصف
أكثر ما صدمني هو الأطفال الذين يعانون من
إصابات فظيعة وفي نفس
الوقت فقدوا والديهم دون
أحد  ومن خلال رعايتهم، فإننا نواجه
وضعًا هنا لن يتم علاجه
عن طريق إرسال المزيد من الشاحنات التي نحتاجها
لتوفير الحماية للمدنيين في
غزة والنساء والأطفال وكبار
السن الذين رأيتهم اليوم والذين
ليس لديهم مكان يذهبون إليه أغلبية الناس.
الأشخاص الذين التقيت بهم اليوم نزحوا
عدة مرات التقيت بأشخاص فقدوا
أطرافهم لأنهم كانوا بحاجة إلى الإخلاء
بين فترات العلاج وفقدوا يدًا
أو قدمًا لأنهم لم يتمكنوا من
العلاج في المستشفى الذي
وصلوا إليه أولاً، قيل لي اليوم أن  لقد
فقد الشمال قدرته الجراحية بالكامل،
وعلينا أن نجد حلولاً لهذا الأمر،
ويمكننا الابتعاد عما يعتبر
فشلاً أخلاقياً واضحاً في مواجهة
المجتمع الدولي، وأنا أدعو جميع الأطراف وكل
من له تأثير إلى
التهدئة وإيجاد الحلول.  وغيرها من
الحلول العسكرية لما يمثل
معاناة هائلة للناس على كلا الجانبين،
علينا أن نحمي حقوق
الناس، علينا أن نحمي حقوق
المدنيين، علينا أن نحمي
حقوق الأشخاص، علينا أن نحمي
حقوق  الرهائن: ستبذل المحكمة الجنائية الدولية قصارى
جهدها للمساعدة في تخفيف
المعاناة وتقليلها، ولكن لا يمكننا القيام
بذلك بمفردنا، وليس هناك
حل إنساني فقط لهذا الأمر، بل يجب أن
يكون هناك حل سياسي.